Gut.
Bitte schön.
Ja.
Jaldus ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station
als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Falls irgendetwas unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen,
soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Albert Dingerdissen.
Ein schwieriger Name.
Ich kann ihn buchstabieren.
Ja, bitte.
Buchstabieren, Nachname insbesondere.
Ja, Albert schreibt sich A, L, B, E, R, T.
Albert.
Der Nachname Dingerdissen, D, I, N, G, E, R, D, I, S, S, E, N.
Dingerdissen.
Ja.
Albert Dingerdissen.
Sprich ich richtig aus.
Ja.
Dingerdissen.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Dingerdissen?
Ich bin 64.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. Januar 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,81 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle, wissen Sie?
82 kg.
Ja, Herr Dingerdissen, was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe so seit sechs Wochen, habe ich Husten
und Luftnot und seit einer Woche ist das noch schlimmer geworden.
Sie haben seit sechs Wochen Husten und Luftnot,
aber letzte ein Woche ist es, ist sie schlimmer geworden.
Versteht ihr gut?
Ja, es ist viel schlimmer geworden.
Ich kann jetzt gar nicht mehr richtig in meine Wohnung kommen,
im zweiten Stockwerk.
Da muss ich zwischendurch 2 Pausen machen,
um da hochzukommen.
Sonst bekomme ich keine Luft und dann muss ich auch stark Husten.
Herr Dingerdissen, haben Sie Luftnot nur bei Belastung
oder in der Ruhe haben Sie Luftnot auch?
Auf alle Fälle bei Belastung, aber seit einer Woche
auch schon etwas in Ruhe, dass ich da schlecht Luft kriege.
Da muss ich insgesamt schneller atmen.
Herr Dingerdissen, haben Sie Auswurf oder Drohkönigusten?
Ich habe viel Auswurf dabei, besonders morgens,
aber das schon länger, habe ich viel Husten
und kommt auch viel Schleim raus.
Wie sieht die Schleim aus, gelblich oder grünlich?
Meistens ist der Schleim gelblich,
aber in den letzten Tagen war es auch etwas bräunlich
und auch etwas rötlich.
Herr Dingerdissen, haben Sie Schmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Schuttelfrost?
Nein, Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht.
Im Winter hatte ich mal eine starke Bronchitis
und da musste ich auch über zwei Wochen
ein Antibiotikum nehmen.
Das war im Januar.
Bronchitis, sagen Sie, richtig?
Ja.
Keine Fieber, keine Schuttelfrost?
Herr Dingerdissen, haben Sie Schwellung
in Ihrem Bein oder Bauch bemerkt?
Nein, meine Beine sind nicht geschwollen.
Gut.
Nein, mein Bauch glaube ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden noch andere Symptome bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich fühle mich nur durch den starken Husten
und durch die Luftnot fühle ich mich ziemlich erschöpft.
Ziemlich müde.
Ziemlich müde, ja.
Herr Dingerdissen, haben Sie Schuttelgang
oder Schuttelgang-Konferenz?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich habe nicht.
Haben Sie Schuttelgang oder Wasserlassengrobleme?
Nein, ich habe Schuttelgang regelmäßig, immer einmal pro Tag.
Beim Wasserlassen muss ich manchmal einmal,
manchmal zweimal nachts auf Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Aber das wurde schon einmal untersucht beim Urologen
und der sagt, ja, die Prostata ist leicht vergrößert,
aber wenn mich das nicht weiter stört, würde er nichts machen.
Und mich stört das auch nicht.
Ich kann danach wieder gut einschlafen.
Gut.
Herr Dingerdsen, haben Sie Windbill?
Nein, Schwindel habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungefähr 6 Monate ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Gut.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankenvorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden die chronische Erkrankungen?
Also ich habe seit 5 Jahren das Gewicht.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden an chronische Bronchitis.
Ja, Bronchitis, das habe ich jetzt schon länger.
Immer wieder Bronchitis im Seen, wie Winter besonders.
Und morgens muss ich oft husten, das habe ich schon länger.
Aber ich habe seit 5 Jahren auch Tabletten gegen Zucker.
Seit 5 Jahren, ja.
Und dann habe ich in den letzten 3 Jahren 2-mal einen Gicht-Anfall gehabt.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft am großen See, am linken Fuß.
Und dann nehme ich auch jetzt ein Medikament ein, damit diese Harnsäure gesenkt wird.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, so lange Jahre für chronische Bronchitis, aber wie lange?
Auch bestimmt 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre.
Ja, okay. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Herr Dingerdsen?
Als Kind, da war ich glaube ich 11 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Leistenbruch operiert auf der linken Seite.
Und dann hatte ich vor vielleicht 18, 19 Jahren hatte ich eine Kniespiegelung.
Auch links, da war mein Meniscus eingerissen.
Und da wurde dieser Meniscus genäht.
Und seitdem habe ich mit dem Knie keine großen Probleme.
Ja.
Herr Dingerdsen, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme einmal Medikamente gegen den Zucker.
Ja.
Was nehmen Sie?
Das Mittel heißt Medformin.
1000 mg oder?
Nein, dahinter steht 850.
850.
Ja, da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch Allopurinol.
Dagegen geht Anfall, ja.
Ja, das klingt 300.
Ja.
Eine Tablette morgens.
Noch andere Medikamente?
Sonst nehme ich nichts.
Ja, gut.
Herr Dingerdsen, sind bei Ihnen einen Allerbien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, sind bei mir nicht bekannt.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, ich rauche schon ziemlich lange, ungefähr 40 Jahre lang.
Ich rauche ungefähr pro Tag eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Aktuelle rauchen Sie auch?
Ja.
Ich kann es nicht lassen.
Ich habe zwar weniger geraucht die letzten Tage.
Und mein Arzt sagt auch, mein Problem ist hauptsächlich das Rauchen.
Daher kommt die Bronchitis, sagt er.
Das sagt auch meine Familie.
Aber ich kann mir im Augenblick nicht vorstellen,
dass ich das Rauchen stoppen kann.
Ich trinke Abend zu zwei kleine Flaschen Bier zum Abendessen oder zum Fernsehschauen.
Herr Dingerdsen, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Dingerdsen, waren Sie in letzter Zeit, ungefähr in den letzten Jahren,
andere Auslande?
Im Ausland.
Im letzten Jahr war ich in Marokko.
Zwei Wochen war ich in Marokko, an der Küste in Agadir.
Aber da ging es mir gut.
Das war ungefähr vor acht Monaten.
Und dann war ich noch jetzt im Herbst, war ich jetzt noch für eine Woche in Kroatien.
In Kroatien?
Ja, eine Woche.
Kroatien.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich glaube ja.
Die letzte Corona-Impfung war jetzt die fünfte.
Die habe ich im Herbst gekriegt, im November, mit einer Grippeimpfung.
Und sonst bin ich, glaube ich, wegen die Sachen alles geimpft, auch gegen Lungenentzündung.
Hat mein Hausarzt gesagt, das ist wichtig für mich, gerade wegen meiner Bronchitis.
Ansonsten, Tetanusimpfung habe ich immer gekriegt, wenn ich mal einen Arbeitsumfall hatte.
Ich glaube, das ist soweit alles aktuell.
Ich würde wissen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben.
Mein Vater ist im Alter von 76 Jahren verstorben, an Lungenkrebs.
Mutter?
Die Mutter ist 92 Jahre alt, die lebt noch.
Die hat sehr stark Brüche geknochen, also so eine Knochenbrüchigkeit.
Vor 20 Jahren hatte die Mutter schwarzen Hautkrebs.
Vor 20 Jahren, ja.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, die hat Asthma, allergisches Asthma.
Und ich habe noch einen Bruder, der hat auch Zucker, der ist 62 Jahre alt.
Und der hat auch sehr hohes Cholesterin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 35 Jahre alt und 37 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich war Schweißer bis vor einem Jahr und dann bin ich in Rente gegangen.
Vor einem Jahr Renter?
Ja, bis dahin habe ich als Schweißer gearbeitet.
Okay.
Herr Dingerdissen, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was kann ich haben?
Weil es macht mir schon Sorge, gerade wenn ich so schlecht Luft bekomme.
Ich kann ja auch die letzten Nächte nicht so gut schlafen,
weil da muss ich häufig erhusten auch.
Und Luftnot habe ich da.
Sonst schlafe ich ja gut, aber die letzten Tage war es nicht gut.
Was kann ich haben? Was kann das sein?
Wegen dieser Beschwerden schlafen Sie nicht gut letzter Zeit.
Ja, in den letzten drei, vier Tagen habe ich schlecht geschlafen.
Ja, ich kann zu wenig zu sagen, wir haben nur diese Aufnahme erhoben.
Wir sollen andere Untersuchungen durchführen, z.B. körperliche Untersuchungen
und Laboruntersuchungen, vielleicht gegebenenfalls Bildgebinde, verfahren.
Nachdem alle Ergebnisse gesammelt haben, können wir wieder ihre Genaudiagnose sprechen.
Okay, so können wir das machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit.
Denken Sie daran die Übersetzung in Fachbegriffe, in Fachsprache.
Ja.
Und die Kollegen und Kollegen, die zugehört und zugeschaut haben,
haben vielleicht noch Ergänzungsfragen.
Haben wir etwas vergessen zu fragen, oder ist irgendwas noch wichtig vom Verständnis her?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Herr Dingerdissen, haben Sie Probleme beim Flachlegen?
Können Sie Flachlegen oder bekommen Sie auch Atemnot beim Flachlegen?
Also ich kann ein Jahrmaßen flachlegen, aber ich brauche schon,
also ein Kissen brauche ich.
Das brauche ich, aber also mehr brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Es ist trotzdem dieser Hustenreiz in der Nacht und auch die schlechte Luft.
Ja, da ist das nicht so gut mit dem Liegen, aber ein Kissen brauche ich.
Und haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolken oder Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein.
Danke.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ja, deswegen dieser Beschwerden jetzt seit der letzten Woche,
also mit Husten und Luftnot, das kenne ich ja so ein bisschen.
Aber ich habe jetzt abgewartet, weil ich kein Fieber hatte.
Im Winter hatte ich ja mal Fieber und da war ich beim Hausarzt
und der hat mir dann auch ein Antibiotikum aufgeschrieben.
Aber jetzt nicht.
Und jetzt geht es mir natürlich seit einer Woche schlechter.
Meine Frau sagt immer, du musst zum Arzt gehen.
Und ich wollte aber nicht.
Deswegen bin ich heute jetzt hier in der Ambulanz.
Haben Sie Blut im Ausruf bemerkt?
Ja.
Ich habe gesagt, das war so manchmal etwas rötlich.
Ja, so richtig dickes Blut nicht, aber es war manchmal etwas rötlich.
Sie ist eher Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist normalerweise gut.
Aber in den letzten Tagen, seitdem ich diese Luftnot habe
und diesen starken Husten, habe ich nicht so gut gegessen.
Aber ist mein Appetit nicht so gut.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Nasenfeststoffung oder O-Geräusch?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, danke.
Okay, können wir erst als Gespräche anfangen?
Ich denke, alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Der Kollege hat das sehr gut gemacht.
Ich habe ihn sehr gut verstanden.
Er sagt, er hat Probleme mit der Sprache.
Ich finde, er hat das sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, danke.
Ich sehe ihn jetzt nur nicht.
Ja, dir?
Ja.
Wann haben wir an?
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Öberth-Arzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin eingenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen sie vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Ja, Herr Albert Dinger-Dissen ist ein 64-jähriger Patient,
zeitlich, wirklich und persönlich orientiert
in normal gewichtiger Ernährungszustand
und in schmerzbedingter, Entschuldiger,
in beschwerter bedingter, deutlich reduzierter Allgemeinzustand.
Das Patient stellte sich heute auf unserer Station
mit seit sechs Wochen bestehenden,
progritierenden Dispne und Tussis
vor, die von Taschipne und Sputum begleitet seien.
Ja.
Abgesehen davon klackte er
über Fatikühe.
Okay.
Nach Aussage der Patient
ist die, sind die beschwerden
in letzter Woche schlimmiger worden.
Ja.
Sie hat der Patient beschrieben, wie das
Sekret aussieht.
Ja, die Sekret aus, als geltlich, zuerst geltlich,
aber letzte Tage bronlich und rötlich aus.
Okay, okay.
Ja.
Und die Vegetative Entschuldige
auf die Frage nach Fieber, Schutelfrost,
Beinödämme und wurde verneint.
Ja.
Die Vegetative Anamnesis ist bis auf die
oben genannten Symptome,
sowie Schmerzbedingter, beschwerter bedingter
Schlafprobleme und auch beschwerter bedingter
Appetitlosigkeit unaufpällig.
Okay.
Auf die Frage nach Schutulgant und Wassernassen,
bis auf einmal oder zweimal Nekturi
wurde verneint.
Okay, gut.
Anvor Erkrankungen,
leider er seit zehn Jahren an chronische Brunsche
und letzte Jahre,
wo der Patient zwei Wochen lange
mit Antibiotik, mit Medikamentös
behandelt wurde.
Ja, im Winter.
Okay, gut.
Außer dem, leider er seit fünf Jahre Diabetes-Militus
und dagegen, leider seit fünf Jahren Diabetes-Militus
mit Medformin,
550 Milligramm.
850 Milligramm,
zweimal täglich behandelt worden sei.
Ja, wird zweimal behandelt.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Ist ein Diabetes-Militus wahrscheinlich Typ 2?
Ja, wahrscheinlich Typ 2, ja.
Außer dem,
habe der Patient vor drei Jahren
zweimal Antibiotik geliebt
und Hodogra,
und die Medikamentös behandelt worden sei.
Womit?
Mit Alloprenol 300 Milligramm,
einmal täglich.
Okay, Sie können vielleicht sagen, es besteht
neben dem Diabetes-Militus Typ 2
eine Hyperurikämie
und mit bisher zweimaliger Atritis-Urika.
Ja, so kann man es sagen.
Also die Grunderkrankung ist ja die Hyperurikämie
und aufgrund dieser Hyperurikämie
kam es zur Atritis-Urika.
Es gibt ja viele Menschen, die eine Hyperurikämie haben,
ohne Atritis-Urika.
Ja, sehr gut.
Der Patient nimmt also diese beiden Medikamente
850, zweimal eine, und Alloprenol 300, einmal eine.
Einmal, ja.
Und als Kind wurde der Patient wegen
linksseitiger Ingüinal-Herni operiert worden.
Operiert, operiert worden, ja.
Operiert worden.
Und er sei mit 18 oder 19 Jahren
wegen rechseitiger Menusküs-Rübhtür
arthroskopisch behindert worden sein.
Ja, aber es war andersrum vor 18 Jahren,
also im Alter von 45 Jahren, also vor 19 Jahren,
erfolgte eine arthroskopische,
wahrscheinlich arthroskopische Miniskus-Teilresekktion
wahrscheinlich,
ja, die Miniskus-Teilresekktion,
die Name, die Name, die Name Sie bitte.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Die Jahre, 18 Jahre oder?
Ja, ich glaube vor 18 Jahren, im Alter von 45 Jahren,
der Patient war 45 Jahre alt,
und jetzt 64 Jahre, dann ist das vor 19 Jahren.
Gut, also die beiden Operationen hat der Patient.
Okay.
Istanbul-Gang, die Başkanin von der
General- und Regierungs-Anhaltung
wird heute vorhanden.
Ich werde heute hier,
kurz nach Ankara,
in Ankara, in der Stadt.
Im Bezug auf Medikation,
Name Erderzeit,
oben genannte Medikamente ein.
Ja.
Und auf die Frage nach allergischen
und Erzweglichkeiten wurden verneint.
Mhm.
Zum Rauchverhalten erklärte der Patient,
seit 40 Jahren lange, Rauch herzusein.
Er rauchte ungefähr ein Schattel-Sigaret täglich.
Gut.
Denken Sie noch dran, es gibt dafür im Medizinischen noch
einen anderen Begriff,
oder wird man etwas anders formuliert.
Wenn ich 40 Jahre lang eine Schachtel pro Tag rauche,
der betrifft 40 Packages.
Nein, es kann sagen 40 Packages, ja.
Das gibt es 40 Packages.
Genau.
Nikotin Abusus, kann man nicht abusus,
Nikotin Abusus von 40 Packages.
Ja, Nikotin Abusus vor 15 Packages.
Er trinkte zwei kleine Flaschen Pia abend regelmäßig,
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Okay.
Und die Familienanamnese,
die Familienanamnese ergab einen Knochen,
berühst viele Metastasien, oder entschuldige
Melanom.
Melanom an...
Wo sind Sie? Bei welchem Familienmitglied?
Bei Vater oder Mutter?
Entschuldige.
Er gab einen Melanom bei der Mutter.
Ein malignes Melanom, ja.
Malignen ist seit 20 Jahren.
Sie hat, sie leidet unter verschiedenen Knochenbrüche.
Haben Sie eine Idee, wie man das bezeichnen kann,
wenn der Knochen brüchig ist?
Wenn der entkalkt ist der Knochen.
Osteoporose.
Die Mutter leidet wahrscheinlich unter einer
frakturierenden Osteoporose.
Bei alten Menschen leider sehr häufig,
besonders bei Frauen, aber auch bei Männer.
Also die Mutter leidet unter einer frakturierenden
Osteoporose. Vor 20 Jahren wurde ein malignes Melanom
der schwarze Hautkrebs diagnostiziert.
Und der Vater?
Der Vater des Patienten sei im Alter von 76 Jahren
an einem Brunschkarzinoma verstorben.
Lungenkarzinom oder Brunschkarzinom.
Was gesagt?
Der Vater ist an Lungenkrebs verstorben.
Wahrscheinlich war es ein Brunschkarzinom.
Okay, hat der Patient Geschwister?
Ja, die Schwester des Patienten leidet an allergisch Asthma.
Der Brunschkarzinom ist leider an Diabetes mellitus und hypercholestrenämie.
Sehr gut.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Der Status sei vollständig und wegen
der Griepen und Corona auch.
Okay, wissen Sie noch den Beruf des Patienten?
Der Beruf?
Der Beruf? Was hat der Patient geplant?
Der Patient, der Schwester.
Mein Kollege hat in den Chat geschrieben,
was Schweißer heißt.
Da habe ich gesehen, Schweißer.
Nein, ich habe nicht gesehen.
Der Schweißer ist ein, glaube ich, sehr anstrengender Beruf.
Und der Beruf des Schweißers ist leider auch,
geht einher häufig mit Lungenerkrankungen.
Die Patienten entwickeln auch ein Asthma
oder manche entwickeln eben andere pulmonale Erkrankungen
aufgrund der Dämpfe, die teilweise entstehen beim Schweißen.
Das ist in den letzten Jahren wohl besser geworden.
Aber wer lange geschweißt hat, glaube ich,
hat keinen gesunden Beruf gehabt.
Da muss man auch dran denken.
Weil der Patientier, den wir hier haben,
hat ja auch, sagen wir mal, Lungenprobleme.
Was ist Schweißer?
Ich verstehe jetzt.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, Sie kannten den Begriff nicht.
Fragen Sie ruhig den Patienten nach.
Sagen Sie, ich kenne diesen Begriff nicht.
Können Sie mir erklären, was ein Schweiß ist?
Darf ich diese Frage?
Ja, gut.
Die Frage dürfen Sie stellen.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, die anonystischen Angaben
deuten am Ende eine Amphisem.
Ja, okay.
Eine Amphisembronchitis?
Die Bronchitis wird auch durch die Schiebbrise von allem
die starke Luftnot und starke Dispno
und Thysis.
Genau.
Und auch Auswurf.
Ja, starke Auswurf.
Teilweise kennen Sie den Begriff,
wenn ein Patient etwas mehr blutigen Auswurf hat.
Kennen Sie den Begriff,
was man da eventuell noch sagt, medizinisch?
Entschuldigen.
Blutiger Auswurf.
Hemoptysen.
Hemoptysen, sehr gut.
Kann man ruhig so sagen.
Ausnordem unterstützen die Risipofakteuren
so wie Ihr Arbeit und
seine Gewohnheit,
Lebensgewohnheit zum Beispiel,
rauchen, meine Verdachtsdiagnose.
Ja, okay.
Also man kann sagen, ich glaube auch,
der Patient hat eine COPD.
Ja, als Zivilisation eine große COPD.
Und auch ein Lungenemphysemen wahrscheinlich.
Lungenemphysemen, COPD und Lungenkarcinoma.
Ist ja oft einhergehend.
Ein Lungenkarcinom, ja,
kann sein, wir haben aber sonst nichts Besonderes.
Er hat keine Gewichtsabnahme der Patient.
Ja, das gibt es noch nicht.
Ich würde sagen, er hat eine COPD
und ein Lungenemphysemen,
wahrscheinlich eher so ein Typ Blue Blouter.
Wobei wir haben jetzt noch nicht genau gefragt.
Eine Kollegin hat glaube ich gefragt,
hat ihre Lippen verfärbt oder so, hat eine Zyranose.
Das fällt dem Patienten oft persönlich nicht auf.
Beim Blue Blouter haben wir das vielleicht.
Ich finde, es geht jetzt nicht um die richtige Diagnose.
Es geht um die richtige Richtung.
Und die richtige Richtung haben Sie sehr gut getroffen.
Und Sie haben das auch sehr gut gemacht, finde ich.
Und ich finde, Sie haben überhaupt keine großen Sprachprobleme.
Sie können sich sehr gut äußern. Sie können das gut.
Im Anfang hätte ich vielleicht Folgendes gemacht.
Und das ist kein Fehler.
Wenn ein Patient kommt und sagt, ich habe starke Luftnot
und starken Husten.
Und ich kann gar nicht mehr die letzte Nacht,
oder konnte ich gar nicht mehr gut schlafen.
Machen Sie als erstes messen Sie bei den Patienten in SBO2,
messen Sie vielleicht den Blutdruck
und machen ein eines Monitor EKG.
Dann haben Sie so Ihre Vitalwerte erfasst.
Ja, ja, das kann ich.
Das können Sie gleich zu Anfang machen.
Sie können sagen, Herr Dingerdissen,
ich möchte kurz unterbrechen.
Ich messe einmal gerade, um mir ein gutes Bild von Ihnen zu machen,
weil Sie gar schlecht Luft bekommen.
Ja.
Dann können Sie das machen.
Das kommt in der Prüfung gut an.
Ja.
Und verstehe ich.
Das ist jetzt nicht dringend notwendig in dem Fall.
Aber es wäre durchaus nicht schlecht.
Ja, erst mal ich denke gut.
Ja, okay.
Also ich finde, Sie haben das sehr gut gemacht.
Und wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Ja, ich habe zwei Monate, 5. Juli.
Ja, toll.
Schön.
Dann wünsche Ihnen weiter gute Vorbereitung.
Dann würde ich sagen,
belassen wir es heute Abend dabei.
Sehen wir uns nächste Woche Donnerstag.
Nächste Woche haben Sie seitens der Vorbereitung
die Vorbereitung der Vorbereitung.
Nächste Woche haben Sie seitens der Vorbereitung.
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Okay, dann wünsche ich allen einen schönen Abend
und machen Sie es gut.
Tschüss.
Inhalt.
Okay, okay.
Tschüss.
Inhalt, tschüss.
Warum?
Ich schick mal da.
Alles.
Ich habe noch ein paar andere.
Hallih.